[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe Zuschauer entschuldigt bitte
meinen etwas schlechteres
Erscheinungsbild wir haben hier jetzt
ein paar Nachtschichten hinter uns aber
ich denke Informationen sind zur Zeit
wichtiger als Schlaf in diesem Video
wollen wir euch wieder mit einer
wichtigen Entwicklung im Zusammenhang
mit der Expansion russlandsvertraut
machen die häufig im Info Dschungel
untergeht für die Zukunft der Welt
jedoch umso bedeutender ist außerdem
beinhaltet dieses Video auch eine sehr
wichtigen und dringenden handlungsaufruf
zum Krieg um die Ukraine den wir auch
mit einem kohärenten Informationsblock
unterfüttert haben falls du nur wegen
dieses handlungsaufrufs hier bist kannst
du direkt zu ihm springen ich habe ihn
in der Kapitelübersicht markiert so und
nun zu Hauptthema unseres Videos in der
Frage hast du jemals darüber nachgedacht
was ein Land braucht um als große
Weltmacht zu gelten und konkret hast du
Russland für eine Supermacht oder besser
gefragt glaubst du dass Russland über
sein Atom
Voraussetzungen verfügt um als solche
angesehen zu werden wie weit ist Moskau
in der Lage seinen Einfluss über den
ganzen Globus auszudehnen
und seid vorsichtig denn trotz allem was
wir in letzter Zeit auf den
Schlachtfeldern in der Ukraine gesehen
haben ist die Antwort alles andere als
einfach viele Faktoren spielen eine
Rolle aber um den Titel einer Supermacht
zu halten sind drei Dinge in globale
Maßstab notwendig erstens militärische
interventions- und
abschreckungsfähigkeit zweitens
politischer Einfluss und Einflussnahme
in internationalen Organisationen und
drittens außerordentliche
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit die
Frage ist also erfüllt Putin Russland
all diese Kriterien in militärischer
Hinsicht ist die Russische Föderation
eindeutig eine Supermacht wir reden hier
über die führende macht nach Zahl der
einsatzfähigen Atom Sprengköpfe fast
darüber hinaus verfügt Russland über
große Streitkräfte die relativ gut
ausgerüstet sind und vor allem von einem
riesigen industriellen militärischen
Komplex unterstützt werden dieser ist
zwar kleiner als der der USA und auch
obwohl er technologisch nicht den
Entwicklungsstand des Westens erreicht
kann man dennoch sagen dass er über
technisch fortschrittliche Waffen
verfügt zweitens hat es auch politischen
Einfluss und Einfluss internationalen
Gremien Russland ist eines der fünf
ständigen Mitglieder des
UN-Sicherheitsrats mit Vetorecht den
gleichen Status haben nur die USA China
Großbritannien und Frankreich wenn wir
jedoch über wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit oder direkten
politischen Einfluss jenseits des
Territoriums der ehemaligen Sowjetunion
sprechen Sie die Sache schon anders aus
Russland ist nicht in der Lage
Drittländer mit Sanktionen zu bestrafen
es hat keine großen Verbündeten die
seinem Beispiel folgen könnten und
wirtschaftskriege kann es nur begrenzt
führen z.B gegen die von russische
Energie abhängigen Europäer wir hoffen
natürlich dass diese Länder ihre
Lektionen Sachen Energie Abhängigkeit
nun wenigstens auf die harte Tour
gelernt haben sie hätten es auch
einfacher haben können wenn sie einfach
drauf gehört hätten was wir Ihnen schon
seit Jahren in unseren Videos erklären
ein weiteres Problem ist dass es
überhaupt nur eine Handvoll Länder gibt
die moskaust politische Führung derzeit
akzeptieren und diese Zahl wird
scheinbar immer kleiner der springende
Punkt ist allerdings der Kreml und der
russische Präsident selbst sind sich
dieser Realität bzw dieser Schwächen
durchaus bewusst und haben sie in ihren
Handlungen bereits einkalkuliert
genau aus diesem Grund versucht sie seit
Jahren ihr eigenes Netzwerk von
Verbündeten Ländern zusammenzustellen
Länder die Russland internationalen
Einfluss die Fähigkeit zur Führung und
Zugang zu neuen Märkten verschaffen und
Achtung wir reden hier nicht über China
er stimmt zwar dass die Chinesisch
russischen Beziehungen sehr wichtig und
grundlegend für den Creme sind aber in
Moskau ist man sich durchaus bewusst
dass Russland nicht das dominierende
Land in dieser Beziehung ist China wird
sie unterstützen wann und wie es hier
passt nicht mehr und nicht weniger
natürlich müssen wir auf jeden Fall
damit rechnen dass im Geheimen bereits
ein detaillierter Ski putinpark
existiert der auch den aktuellen
Überfall auf die Ukraine beinhaltet denn
wenn jetzt viele Beobachter auch wir
sagen dass Putin seinen Verstand
verloren haben muss und die Invasion
irrational ist müssen wir bedenken dass
diese Einschätzung vielleicht einfach
nur darauf basiert dass wir sie von der
falschen Handlungsebene aus betrachten
wenn wir nämlich in Betracht ziehen dass
der hohe Preis den Russland für sein
Angriffskrieg bezahlen müssen von einer
russisch chinesischen Allianz eben schon
im Rahmen einer größeren globalen
Rechnung einkalkuliert wurde und die
Ukraine nur als Ablenkungsmanöver für
die Invasion ist viel wichtigeren Taiwan
dient macht das alles auch für Putin
wieder Sinn
auf diese Ebene würde er wieder
vollkommen rational handeln denn zu
Beginn eines neuen Weltkriegs so jener
Koalition zu gehören welche die
chip-fabriken auf von Moser kontrolliert
ist ein so gewaltiger Gewinn dass ein
paar Sankt Hühnchen da nicht weiter ins
Gewicht fallen werden und glaubt mir
dieses Szenario haben auch die
Regierungschef viele andere Länder rund
um den Globus von ihren Geheimdiensten
auf dem Tisch liegen und sie alle müssen
sich nun überlegen auf welcher Seite sie
stehen wollen auf dieser Grundlage
versucht Russland ein eigenes Netzwerk
von Verbündeten rund um den Erdball
aufzubauen am besten im Verborgenen aber
wie weit reichen die Tentakel Moskau
welche Instrumente benutzen Wladimir
Putin um den russischen Einfluss
auszuweiten und wann hat er mit all dem
eigentlich angefangen nun ja seit ein
1999 die Präsidentschaft Übernahme
gehörte es zu einer seiner Obsessionen
sich mit dem Oligarchen Russland zu
umgeben jenen großen mafia-bossen welche
sich sowohl die offizielle als auch die
Schattenwirtschaft und die Unterwelt des
Riesenreiches unter den Nagel gerissen
haben insbesondere natürlich die
Energieunternehmen
Putin Strategie war von Anfang an halte
deine Freundin nach und deine Feinde
näher und sein Ziel die Kontrolle über
sie alle zu erlangen und wisst ihr was
putin ist das bravoös gelungen die
meisten der großen Unternehmen des
Landes richten sich heute direkt nach
dem Interessen des Staates und ihr wisst
ja wie es in einem absolutistischen
System ist der Staat und der Herrscher
sind identisch putin ist der Start und
er hat die Energiekonzerne zur
Speerspitze seiner Außenpolitik gemacht
wir sprechen hier über ein Modell das
auf Gefälligkeiten Erpressung und
Privilegien aller Art beruht man kann
sagen dass das russische
Regierungsmodell auf dem Prinzip eine
Hand wäscht die andere basiert es ist
ein Spiel und Gefälligkeiten dass du
100% in Hinterzimmern hinter
verschlossenen Türen entschieden wird in
diesem Video werden wir daher der
wichtigen Fragen nachgehen wie der Bus
Putin mit Hilfe seiner Kapos den großen
oleganischen den russischen Einfluss im
Ausland nach und nach ausweitet und
welche Pläne er in Zukunft hat wir haben
es mit nichts anderem als die
mächtigsten Schwert der globalen
russischen Macht zu tun
muss ich mich mit einem wichtigen Appell
einem direkten handlungsaufruf an jeden
von euch richten zum Zeitpunkt des Drehs
dieses Videos verhandeln die Regierung
der EU gerade über ein Sanktionspaket
gegen Russland wie wir euch jedoch in
einem früheren sogar vor dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine aufgenommen Video erklärt
haben hat Putin sein Land mit der
Festung großlandstrategie gegen all
diese Sanktionen abgehärtet über Jahre
hinweg hat er genau jene Kriegskasse
gefüllt aus der er nun das Morden in der
Ukraine finanziert aber Moment mal denn
das ist nicht die ganze Wahrheit wir
alle haben sie für ihn gefüllt jedes Mal
wenn wir den Thermostat an unserer Gas
oder Ölheizung aufgedreht haben ebenso
wie an den Zapfsäulen und jedes Mal wenn
wir Geld für Produkte oder Strom
ausgegeben haben für die ein Produktion
ebenfalls diese Rohstoffe benötigt
werden auch wenn es ganz viele nicht
wahrhaben wollen Deutschland finanziert
Putins Krieg die Zahlen lügen nicht im
Jahr 2020 zahlte die EU 64,2 Milliarden
Euro für mineralexporte an Russland und
was schätzt ihr wie
61,7 Milliarden der Handel mit Energie
Rohstoffen Macht 1/5 des russischen
Staatshaushalts aus die Hälfte davon
bezahlt die EU und der Löwenanteil davon
kommt wiederum aus Deutschland die
deutschen stecken also als finanzierst
bis zum Hals in diesem Krieg und das
obwohl schon seit 2014 klar war das ist
dringend geboten ist die fatale
Energieabhängigkeit der größten
Volkswirtschaft Europas von Russland zu
eliminieren oder wenigstens abzubauen
aber das Gegenteil war der Fall Putin
gelang ist Europa und vor allem
Deutschland noch abhängiger zu machen
auch dank der exzellenten Lobbyarbeit
seiner zahlreichen Amigos in Berlin wie
z.B Exkanzler Gerhard Schröder der
russische Präsident wusste im Gegensatz
zu sein EU-Kollegen nämlich genau was er
tat das Reich von Vladimir Putin ist ein
typischer pedrostaat ein Land das als
Dauerpatient der holländischen Krankheit
keine Dynamik entfaltet auch auf anderen
Sektoren global wettbewerbsfähig zu
werden schon vor 20 Jahren war es die
große Frage wann wird Russland auch
Autos Computer oder Mode exportieren die
Antwort zeigt uns die Statistik der
russischen Exporte wo neben roh immer
noch keine anderen Produkte in
nennenswerten Umfang auftauchen
Deutschland besetzt dabei die Hauptrolle
in diesem geopolitischen Trauerspiel die
größte Volkswirtschaft der EU und die
viertgrößte der Erde importierten
absoluten Zahlen mit weitem Abstand das
meiste Gas aus Russland zwar haben
manche osteuropäische Staaten prozentual
höhere Anteile dabei handelt es sich
aber oft um historisch Verpflichtungen
aus der Zeit des Kommunismus während
Deutschland aber mit nostring 1 und 2
viele Jahre lang die Abhängigkeit von
russischem Gas gefestigt hat bemühen
sich viele andere Länder diese zu
reduzieren
so haben etwa die baltischen Staaten
oder Polen Terminals gebaut um dort LNG
aus anderen Ländern importieren zu
können und Deutschland Hilft Putin auch
auf der import-seite es liefert jede
Menge Fahrzeuge Maschinen Chemieprodukte
und Elektronik gleichwohl haben etliche
deutsche Unternehmen
Produktionskapazitäten und das
Serviceeinheiten in Russland aufgebaut
die deutschen Investitionen im
putinreich bewegen sich in einer
Größenordnung von jährlich rund 20
Milliarden Euro denn deutsche
Unternehmen produzieren sehr häufig
genau jene Produkte die Russland
dringend benötigt umgekehrt sind
russische Unternehmen in Deutschland im
Vergleich dazu recht unbedeutend es geht
um noch nicht mal 4 Milliarden Euro die
Bedeutung russischer Firmen für das
Wirtschaftsgeschehen in der
Bundesrepublik ist daher vergleichsweise
geringt gut was bedeutet das alles nun
vor allem dass Deutschland was
handelssanktion angeht gegenüber
Russland eigentlich einen riesen
hebesitz einem Hebel der so groß ist
dass er durchaus das Potential hätte die
Festung Russland zu knacken das Problem
die jetzige Regierung und der Kanzler
Scholz schwingt große Reden wagte es
aber noch nicht einmal an ihrem großen
Hebel der ihr eine gewaltige
Verantwortung die Geschehnisse in der
Ukraine überträgt auch nur ansatzweise
zu kitzeln allein als es um den
Ausschluss Russlands aus dem Swift
System gegen diskutierte sie nur ewig
herum und verschenkte wertvolle Zeit die
Menschenleben gekostet hat aber diese
Ausschluss ist wie ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein im Vergleich zu einem
vollständigen handelsembalgo der EU und
auch der USA welche auch große Mengen
Erdöl aus Russland beziehen und an
dieser Stelle kommen wir alle ins Spiel
denn wenn die Regierung nicht wollen
müssen die Parlamente Druck auf sie
ausüben im Zweifel können Sie die
Regierung da legislativ zum Handeln
zwingen durch ein entsprechendes Gesetz
und die Parlamentarier müssen dafür
Druck von uns allen bekommen sie müssen
wissen dass es uns nicht egal ist dass
wir auch bereit sind Opfer zu bringen
nicht nur für die Menschen in der
Ukraine sondern für unsere eigene
Freiheit denn jedes Zeichen von Schwäche
wird Putin nur dazu nutzen um ihn noch
weiter zu gehen er lacht über uns wenn
er sieht dass uns eine günstige warme
Dusche wichtiger ist als jede Werte von
denen wir immer groß schwagonieren und
wisst ihr was dabei im Grunde vollkommen
Recht eine solche Haltung ist
verachtenswert und ich wundere mich
nicht dass er es in seiner kruden
darwinistischen Logik als pure
Konsequenz ansieht dass eine derart
dekadente Kultur durch eine härtere
widerstandsfähigere unterworfen wird
also was können wir tun nun das aller
Mindeste ist dass jeder von uns seinen
Bundestagsabgeordneten kontaktiert und
ihm oder ihr klar macht dass wir unsere
Wahlentscheidung in Zukunft ganz klar
davon abhängig machen werden ob sie oder
er nun handelt und eine
Gesetzesinitiative für ein vollständiges
handelsenbargo gegen Russland auf den
Weg bringen bzw unterstützt keine halben
Sachen mehr denn sie sind jetzt der Weg
in die Hölle welche Abgeordnete für dich
zuständig ist erfährst du z.B auf
Abgeordneten watch indem du dort deine
Postleitzahl angibst auf der Seite gibt
es auch Kontaktmöglichkeiten und ich
werde sie euch in der Beschreibung zu
diesem Video verlinken generell gilt
dabei Höflichkeit siegt wir wollen die
Abgeordneten informieren und nicht
beleidigen aber lasst euch nicht
abwimmeln macht klar dass ihr nur
denjenigen Kandidaten wählen werdet denn
dieser Frage absolut kategorisch handelt
ohne jedes lavieren und Wischiwaschi
Abgeordnete haben öfters
Bürgersprechstunden in ihrem Wahlkreis
diese werden in der Regel auf der
Abgeordneten Website veröffentlicht da
kann man hingehen und sein Anliegen
vorbringen ihr könnt dort z.B die
Argumentation aus unseren Videos
vorbringen und dem Abgeordneten vorab
per Mail oder Nachricht einen Link
darauf zu senden damit sich diese auf
das Thema des Gesprächs vorbereiten kann
ihr könnt ihn auch links und Auszüge aus
den Artikel zusenden die ich euch als
Quellen unten in der Beschreibung zu
diesem Video angegeben habe falls er
keine Zeit hat für einen Besuch könnt
ihr Abgeordnete auch anrufen in der
Regel gehen jetzt bei dem Mitarbeiter
ans Telefon aber ihr könnt sie dann nett
um den Rückruf des Abgeordneten bitte
viele Abgeordnete werden auf die
jeweiligen Experten in der Fraktion
verweisen lasst euch hier nicht
abwimmeln es ist euer Abgeordneter ihr
seid also Wähler und souverän sein Boss
vor allem wenn der Abgeordnete aus dem
eigenen Wahlkreis kommt generell solltet
ihr mit Abgeordneten aller Parteien
sprechen im Moment jedoch vor allem mit
denen der Regierungsparteien erwähnt den
gegenüber aber gerne dass ihr auch mit
dem Oppositionskandidaten gesprochen
habt dieser euer Anliegen unterstützt
Wettbewerb bläht schließlich die
Demokratie so nun aber genug des
bürgerkundeunterrichts jetzt seid ihr an
der Reihe wobei auch hier Geld dies ist
keine Übung das hier ist der Ernstfall
handelt also bitte entsprechend und ja
die Abgeordneten werden euch mit
Argumenten kommen wie die Inflation wird
noch weiter angeheizt Unternehmen werden
zahlungsunfähig werden und so weiter und
so fort aber das galt ja auch für die
corona-lockdowns und hier waren sie alle
schnell bei der Sache ohne Rücksicht auf
Wirtschaft und gesamtgesellschaftliche
kosten diese Argument zieht also
überhaupt nicht denn auch hier geht es
um Menschenleben und es geht um die
Freiheit Europas denn wenn Putin sieht
dass sich die europäischen Warmduscher
noch nicht mal zu einem vollständigen
handelsembalko aufhaben können wird er
so gleich zum nächsten Test übergehen
dem NATO Verteidigungsfall fragt also
eure Abgeordneten ob sie es wirklich
darauf ankommen lassen wollen der Preis
den wir wirklich harte Sanktionen die
auch etwas bewirken würden zahlen müssen
ist nichts wenn wir damit den großen
Krieg in Europa verhindern können Teil
dieses Video bitte auch so viel in eurer
Freunde wie möglich damit auch Sie
unserem Aufruf folgen können falls ihr
selbst Medien schaffen oder
Multiplikatoren seid übernimmt bitte
diesen Appell in eure Videos Podcast
Blocks Artikel und Sendungen ihr könnt
dazu beliebig Ausschnitte aus diesem
Video verwenden diese handlungsaufruf
steht natürlich unter der Creative
Commons Lizenz ich bitte euch schnell zu
handeln damit diese Regierung endlich
begreift das ist hier um die Wurst geht
das hier die Stunde da Wahrheit schlägt
und mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wird es
keine zweite Chance geben ca vor einer
Stunde bekam ich eine E-Mail von meinem
Webhosting Provider ich solle alle meine
Daten bei ihm sicher sowohl online als
auch offline da er vom sicherheitsamt
für Informationstechnik die Meldung
bekommen Russland hätte bereits mit dem
Einsatz der Maler Hermetic Viper in
Lettland und Litauen begonnen dabei
handelt es sich genau um jedes Wort
damit welcher im Vorfeld des Überfalls
auf die Ukraine deren Serversystem
angegriffen und gelöscht wurden also es
ist Eile angesagt und die Einschläge
kommen näher und wir stecken in diesem
Krieg bereits mittendrin ob wir es
wollen und wahrhaben wollen oder nicht
ich danke euch für euer Engagement und
nun lasst uns zum eigentlichen Thema
dieses Videos kommen unterfrage
nachgehen wie Boss Putin mit Hilfe
seiner Oligarchen in russischen Einfluss
im Ausland nach und nach ausweitet
Putin Kapos die Oli karchen
lasst uns die Dinge ins rechte Licht
drücken auf den Zusammenbruch der
Sowjetunion folgte eine Zeit der Krise
und des politischen Niedergangs die bei
einem großen Teil der russischen
Bevölkerung einen Traum ja fast eine
Besessenheit auslöste die einstige Größe
macht und den Einfluss in der Welt
wieder zu erlangen das liegt auch daran
dass wirtschaftlicher Wohlstand und
Karrierechancen nicht für alle aber für
sehr viele Russen eher zweitrangige
Ziele sind zuallererst geht es um die
Stärke den Einfluss und die Macht des
Mutterlandes Russland und weißt du was
seitdem Putin an der Macht ist verfolgt
er die Erfüllung genau dieser Vision
nationale Stärke steht über allen
anderen Fragen aber angesichts der
wirtschaftlichen Zwänge des an der
holländischen Krankheit einen
pedrostatus Russland stellt sich
natürlich die große Frage wie um alles
in der Welt kann man diese Vision
umsetzen wie kommt man an einen
Druckmittel gegen die USA selbst
nun es stellt sich heraus dass Putins
Regierung nichts Geringeres getan hat
als zu versuchen genau jene Länder ins
Netz zu bekommen die für die anderen
Großmächte nicht besonders interessant
sind ein gutes aktuelles Beispiel finden
wir in ja genau im jüngsten großen
Fehlschlag der US Außenpolitik den
islamischen Emirat Afghanistan heute es
ist eines der ersten instabilsten und
unruhigsten Länder der Welt welches
jetzt ins Visier Russlands geraten ist
Terrorismus die hat es muss und das ein
oder andere Energieprojekt haben Moskau
dazu gebracht das Land der Taliban
genauer unter die Lupe zu nehmen unter
anderem deshalb weil Moskau am meisten
Angst davor hat dass dieses Land zu
einem Epizentrum des Dschihadismus
werden könnte so eine Operationsbasis
für radikale Gruppen vergiss nicht das
Russland bereits ein wachsendes Problem
mit diesem Thema hat große Teile der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion sind zu einem
fruchtbaren Boden für jihadistische
Radikalisierung geworden in Russland
leben nicht nur mehr als 20 Millionen
Muslime sondern es ist auch das Land in
dem da echt die meisten ausländischen
Kämpfer rekrutieren konnte
mach den Rückzug der USA da muss kaum
die Notwendigkeit Einfluss zu gewinnen
und die Geschehnisse im islamischen
Emirat Afghanistan genau zu beobachten
und um dies zu erreichen hat Putins
Regierung die Dienste der mit ihnen
befreundeten Oligarchen sprich Mafia
Bosse genutzt aber diese sind ja auch
nur Menschen Menschen die eben ganz
menschliche Eigenschaften Bedürfnisse
und Beziehungen haben und natürlich auch
Namen einer davon ist hier die
victorovic spricht dieser Mann ist der
Besitzer der Lieblingsrestaurant des
russischen Präsidenten deshalb auch als
Putins Koch bekannt Essen Gregorian hat
jedoch auch noch ein anderes sehr
nützliches Talent welches ihn als engen
Freund und Verbündeten Putins besonders
wertvoll macht einen Teil seines
Vermögens setzt er zu Finanzierung
politischer und paramilitärische
Aktivitäten im Ausland ein wir sprechen
über einen der mächtigsten Akteure in
den politischen Kreisen Russlands einen
der wichtigsten und mächtigsten
Oligarchen des Landes und nein es geht
nicht um Erdgas Erdöl und Rohstoffe sein
Business sind Restaurants
na ja nicht ganz Restaurants und Zöllner
Jewgeni trikotin ist so etwas wie der
Schatten des kriebels ein Mann der mit
Mission betraut wird welche die
russische Regierung nicht offiziell wie
ihre eigenen aussehen lassen möchte eine
Figur die praktisch das Monopol besitzt
Russland Ambitionen auf den Nahen Osten
und Afrika zu projizieren im Gegenzug
dafür hat er freie Hand bei der
Verfolgung seiner eigenen Ziele in Putin
Russland wäscht eben eine Hand die
andere und ich bin mir sicher dass ich
viele von euch fragen wie er das alles
eigentlich angestellt hat wie übt er
seinen Einfluss aus nun brikochen ist
der Gründer der wagnergruppe die
wagnergruppe ist eine paramilitärische
Organisation mit einem internationalen
Netzwerk von Söldner und zwielichtigen
Geschäften die in Ländern operieren in
denen du wahrscheinlich keinen Urlaub
machen möchtest die Warengruppe hat
paramilitärische Kräfte in Ländern wie
Syrien Libyen und dem Sudan eingesetzt
und wird sogar mit dem Einmarsch in die
Ukraine im Jahr 2014 in Verbindung
gebracht sowie der jahrelangen
Unterstützung des Separatisten in
Dornbach und nicht nur das ihn werden
auch Interventionen in
russlandfreundlichen L du geschrieben
und pro demokratische Proteste zu
unterdrücken und alle Arten von Westen
Informationskampagnen und Operation
unter falscher Flagge durchzuführen
die Londoner Times berichtet gerade zum
Zeitpunkt des Drehs dieses Videos das
mehr als 400 Völker der Gruppe nach Kiew
entsandt worden um auch Befehl des Kreml
den ukrainischen Präsidenten
bologneselenski und Mitglieder seine
Regierung zu ermorden demnachflog
brikosion bereits vor 5 Wochen Söldner
aus Afrika 1 die dort unter anderem in
Mali im libyschen Bürgerkrieg und der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik im Einsatz
waren ihr kommandoör hat seine Söldner
terra-truppe übrigens nach dem
Komponisten Richard Wagner benannt da
dieser als judenhauser Geld und Option
ein bekennender Verehrer Hitlers und des
Dritten Reich der Nationalsozialisten
ist wir drücken Präsident selenski alle
Daumen dass er Putin smartbande
überlistet denn gerade selenski ist mit
seinem überragenden Mut Charisma
Entschlossenheit und seinen exzellenten
Kommunikationsfähigkeiten die stärkste
Waffe jedes Landes dessen Volk mit
seiner eigenen Haut gerade für unser
aller Freiheit kämpft ja die Ukraine ist
momentan das tapferste und zugleich das
wichtigste Land der Welt und
potentiellensky der wird bereits zu
Jahresbeginn den visualpolitik im Wort
als Politiker des Jahres 2021 verliehen
haben ist im Augenblick wohl habe fast
so und wichtigste Mensch der Welt das
entsprechende Video werde ich euch
natürlich verlinken denn es ist schon
eine wahrlich gerechte Ironie des
Schicksals die sich da gerade
manifestiert da bastelt Pute Jahre lang
an seinem zärbild als harter
heldenhafter Ex KGB-Agent der auf Bären
reitet auf Tsunamis surft Chuck Norris
ohrfeigt
auf einen Torwart schießt der sich nicht
hört weil er sonst im Gulag landet
mit Kaviar genießt während er seine
Soldaten zu Kanonenfutter macht und
unschuldige zivilistenmorgen lässt ist
der wahre Held der ehemalige Komiker
selensky der sein Land tapfer und mit
einem Lächeln verteidigt und als Gipfel
dieser wahrlich atemberaubenden
Heuchelei deklariert Putin seine
Mordaktion mit der er den bekennenden
Nazi Unken beauftragt hat als
Entnazifizierung man muss sich das mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen selensky
ist Jude seine Großvater hat in der
Roten Armee gegen die Nazis gekämpft ein
großer Teil seiner Familie wurde damals
von ermordet und mit
Premierminister war die Ukraine das
zweite Land der Welt nach Israel das
sowohl einen jüdischen Präsidenten als
auch Premierminister hatte na ja es ist
schon lange bekannt dass ich die neuen
waren Faschisten heute Antifaschisten
nennen aber Putin setzt auch diesen
ganzen Kranken Lügengebäude nochmals die
Krone auf aber zurück zur wagnergruppe
diese Gruppe soll sich jedoch auch der
Förderung von Gold und Diamanten widmen
höchstwahrscheinlich auch illegal mieten
ja es handelt sich nicht gerade um einen
Wohlfahrtsverein oder ein Unternehmen
dass ich mit soziale Verantwortung
Umwelt und eine ethisch sauberen
Unternehmenskultur beschäftigt und daher
ist die Evgeni brigosch in einer Jena
illegalischen die unter US Sanktion
stehen ja wir können soweit gehen zu
sagen dass Russland so etwas wie zwei
Außenministerien und zwei
Verteidigungsministerien hat da gibt es
lavrov unschuldigung als offizielle
Minister und bring Goschen der in
verborgenen agiert nun stellt sich
heraus dass dieser russische Oligarch
auch der Hauptfinanzier der sogenannten
Stiftung zum Schutz nationaler Werte
kurz fznc ist
die Stiftung vom schutznationaler Werte
ist eine Organisation die in mehreren
Ländern in Afrika und Zentralasien
vertreten ist
im Falle Afghanistans war sein
Vertrauter vor Ort Maxim schugali einer
der ersten die nach der Machtübernahme
der Taliban in Kabul eintrafen sogar
alle kontrolliert ein politisches
Netzwerk Unterhalt der fznc das versucht
Bereiche der Sicherheit und auch der
wirtschaftlich Zusammenarbeit zwischen
der Taliban und Russland zu finden sie
suchen nach Bereichen der Zusammenarbeit
und sind natürlich über alles informiert
was in dem Land passiert und vergiss
nicht dass wir hier nicht von
irgendeinem daher gelaufenen Heini
sprechen sondern von einem hochkarätigen
Soziologen und internationalen Experten
des jahrzehntelange Erfahrung
seinesgleichen sucht
so wurde er z.B im Juli 2019 bis
Dezember 2020 in Libyen inhaftiert weil
er sich mit
dem Sohn des ehemaligen
getroffen hat um ihn zu ermutigen den
Sprung an die politische Freund zu wagen
was genau wollen Putin brigochen und
sugari also von der Taliban
nun eine der direkten folgendes
Aufstiegs nataliban ist die
internationale Isolation des Landes nur
sehr wenige Länder wollen offiziell
Beziehungen zu Afghanistan unterhalten
wenn die Taliban also Geld Waffen
Energie oder Informationen brauchen um
ihre Macht zu festigen an wen können
sich da besser wenden als an den
russischen Bären klar da war zwar vor
ein paar Jahrzehnten was mit einer
Invasion und jahrelangem brutalen Krieg
und so aber Schwamm drüber aussehen und
Völkerverständigung sind doch das
Wichtigste überhaupt oder eher
gemeinsame Interessen und Feinde aber
was kann Russland überhaupt aus einem so
unwirtlichen verarmten und trostlosen
Ort wie Afghanistan herausholen selbst
wenn es der einflussreichste
ausländische Akteur im ganzen Land wird
was will man mit Einfluss in einem so
trostlosen Land nun wie gesagt geht es
z.B darum zu verhindern dass Afghanistan
zu einer Operationsbasis für
skihadistische Gruppen wird die Moskau
als Bedrohung betrachtet aber das ist
nicht alles Moskau verfolgt auch das was
man als geostrategische Ziele bezeichnen
könnte da wären zum einen die riesigen
Vorkommen an begehrten Mineralien wie
Lithium möge die Afghanistan aber es
geht auch um strategisch wichtige
Projekte wie dieses
was du hier siehst ist das tapi-projekt
eine riesige Gaspipeline durch die nach
ihrer Fertigstellung große Mengen
gasrückministan nach Indien und Pakistan
transportiert werden können wir sprechen
von mindestens 33 Milliarden Kubikmeter
in Gas pro Jahr in der ersten Phase
Kaliban Regime Welt 30.000 Soldaten
entsenden um die Arbeit am TAPI
Gaspipeline Projekt wieder aufzunehmen
aber das ist noch nicht alles sieh dir
mal die folgende Karte an
Afghanistan könntest du Indien und
Pakistan zwei Länder mit mehr als 1,6
Milliarden Einwohnern das sind 20% der
Weltbevölkerung das werden was die
Ukraine seit Jahren für die Europäische
Union ist ein unverzichtbares
strategisches Transitland um einen
enormen Strom von Erdgas und Erdöl aus
dem reichen vorkommt in Zentralasien zu
erhalten und weißt du was die Russen
wollen schon seit Jahren in dieses
Geschäft einsteigen
Russland ist an einer Beteiligung am Bau
der tabi-pipeline interessiert und die
Frage ist warum interessiert sich
Russland ausgerechnet so sehr für dieses
Projekt ohne wesentlichen aus zwei
Gründen erstens ist Russland ein großer
Exporteur vom Erdgas die Teilhabe an
einer der vielleicht wichtigsten
Transportrouten der Welt würde seinen
Einfluss im Energiebereich erheblich
stärken und zweitens wenn diese Route
konsolidiert wird könnten Russland sie
in Zukunft nutzen um sein eigenes Gas
und Öl zu exportieren der schätzungen
gehen davon aus dass in den nächsten
jahrzehn von Gas und Öl nur so
verschlingen wird und glaub mir wenn ich
dir sage dass die Russen ernsthaft nach
alternativen Kunden zu den europäischen
Volkswirtschaften aber auch so China
suchen die afghanische Route und die
Verbindung mit Indien könnten einen Weg
sein um einen neuen Großkunden zu
gewinnen in diesem Sinne könnte die TAPI
Pipeline erweitert und schließlich mit
den neuen Erdgasfeldern verbunden werden
die Russland und Kasachstan im
Kaspischen Meer gerade erschließen es
handelt sich um einen Joint Venture
zwischen dem größten kasachischen
Gaskonzern und einem russischen
Konstruktion besteht aus Look all und
Gazprom beide Länder sind zu jeweils 50%
an dem Projekt beteiligt und für gastron
handelt es sich nicht weniger als die
größte Wette des rohstoffriesen im
Kaspischen Meer ja wer hätte gedacht
dass eine so verarmte und trostlose
Gegend die Afghanistan doch noch so
wichtig haben könnte und um
sicherzustellen dass alles unter
Kontrolle ist bauen die russischen
oleganischen dort ihre Einfluss und
überwachungsnetzwerke im ganzen Land auf
im Gegenzug erhalten die talibanen
Waffen Militärberater Energie
Lieferungen verschiedenster Art und
sogar Geld wenn nötig Russland bietet
über die wagnergruppe eine rundum
Sorglos-Paket an glaub aber keinen
Moment dass dies das einzige Beispiel
ist das für finden können ein Blick auf
den afrikanischen Kontinent und
Lateinamerika zeigt dass es Moskau
darauf abgesehen hat wieder eine echte
globale Supermacht zu werden also
aufgepasst
der russische Quelle Katalog
ja der Einfluss der Vereinigten Staaten
unserer westlichen Verbündeten ist ohne
Zweifel sehr sehr groß aber es ist auch
wahr dass dieser Einfluss an manchen
Orten viel begrenzter ist als ein
anderer das ist kein großes Geheimnis
und wir haben hier auch wieso alle
Politik schon darüber gesprochen China
ist einfach in Afrika hat in den letzten
Jahren stark zugenommen durch
Investitionen den Bau von Infrastruktur
Handelsabkommen und Technologietransfer
hatte chinesische Regierung viel
Einfluss und neue Kunden und Lieferanten
für ihre Unternehmen gewonnen und in
gewisser Weise versucht Russland eine
analoge Strategie zu fahren natürlich
ist Russland so sehr Putin auch Schmerz
nicht China Moskau hat bei weitem nicht
so viel Geld im Portemonnaie wie Peking
und es hat auch nicht zu viele
interessante Produkte in seinem
Portfolio der Kabel musste also nach
anderen sagen wir einfallsreicheren
Wegen suchen um sich durchzusetzen
ebenfalls von Afrika will Russland ein
wichtiger Lieferant von Getreide
Medikamenten und energiewerken ein
Beispiel dafür ist das Russland mit mehr
als 7,5 Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr
bereits für das 100 Millionen Land
Ägypten der größte Exporteur für Weizen
ist außerdem will es seine umfangreichen
Erfahrungen nutzen um Bergbau und
Energieprojekte in Ländern wie Simbabwe
Angola und Burkina Faso zu fördern
erinnerst du dich an den guten alten
Evgeni pregorian wo die jetzt Koch nun
es ist bekannt dass seine Unternehmen
Konzession zum Abbau von Diamanten und
Gold in der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik erhalten haben ein anderes
Beispiel gefällig Sergej evanoff der
Sohn des ehemaligen russischen
Verteidigungsministers ist sie auch von
alrosa einem russischen
Bergbauunternehmen das auf
Industriediamanten spezialisiert ist
denn russland hat zwar nicht so viel
Wirtschaftskraft wie China die USA oder
die EU aber es hat etwas das viele
autokratische Regierungen unbedingt
haben wollen Waffen wenig Skrupel und
viel Erfahrung in Sachen Geheimdienste
Unterdrückung und Sicherheit
zur Veranschaulichung erinnerst du dich
noch an die wagnergruppe die wir bereits
erwähnt haben gut dann sieh dir mal das
hier an in den letzten Jahren wurden
Auftragnehmer der wagnergruppe im
gesamten Nahen Osten und Afrika
eingesetzt darunter in Syrien Jemen
Libyen Sudan Mosambik Madagaskar der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik und Mali
sie haben sich vor allem auf den Schutz
der herrschenden Eliten und kritischer
Infrastrukturen konzentriert darüber
hinaus sind die Russen und die Chinesen
sehr pragmatisch sie fragen mich nach
Dingen wie Menschenrechten Demokratie
oder der Umwelt und um Geschäfte machen
zu können in Ländern dieser Art ist es
eben ein großer Vorteil wenn man keine
1000 Nachhaltigkeit Zertifikate für
seine Lieferkette braucht und wisst ihr
was der Modus Operandi hier ist dem was
wir in Afghanistan gesehen haben sehr
ähnlich russische Oligarchen etablieren
sich vor Ort und suchen Vereinbarungen
mit lokalen Managern Manager die auf
diese Art wichtige Werkzeuge für den
Erhalt ihrer Macht erhalten wie z.B den
Zugang zum kompletten Katalog der
russischen Militärindustrie mit einem
speziellen Abschnitt für Zöllner
Erfahrung die Technologie und das
Know-how dass Sie brauchen um ihre
natürlichen Ressourcen ausbeuten zu
können
im Gegenzug erhält Russland politischen
Einfluss neue Kunden und natürlich auch
eine weitere Bereicherung für die
kriminalen Oligarchen von Libyen bis
Nigeria und von Äthiopien bis Mali hat
Moskau in den letzten Jahren mehr als 20
Militärabkommen auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent geschlossen dadurch ist
Russland zum größten Exporteur von
militärgern nach Afrika geworden sein
Marktanteil liegt bei fast 50% nur damit
du dir ein Bild machen kannst 13
September 2021 russland baut seine
militärischen Einfluss in Afrika aus und
fordert die Vorherrschaft der USA und
Frankreichs heraus so 2 Oktober 2021
Marlies Plan russisches Söldner als
Ersatz für französische Truppen
einzusetzen verunsichert die salzzone
und abgesehen von der Ukraine und den
großen Schlagzeilen versucht Moskau auf
diese Weise sein politischen Einfluss in
der Welt zu vergrößern und neue Märkte
für neue Produkte zu erschließen und was
noch wichtiger ist es bekommt die Dollar
die seine Militärunternehmen brauchen um
Ihre Ausrüstung weiter aufzurüsten das
ist also die Formel die Russland nutzt
um jeden Einfluss zu bekommen den man
benötigt wieder zu einer globalen
Supermacht zu werden und in dieser
Formel spielen russische origarchen und
Großunternehmen eine Schlüsselrolle
überall wo der Westen an Boden verliert
haben China und auch Russland sofort
ihren Fuß in der Tür und glaubt nicht
eine Sekunde daran dass ich diese Länder
darum scheren was Putin in der Ukraine
anstellt sie selbst sind meist durch
jahrelange Kriege und Interventionismus
abgestopft oft rücksichtslos vom Westen
auf ihren Rücken ausgetragen in
Verbindung mit Putins brutale Masterplan
das große russische Kolonialreich wieder
aufzubauen von dem wir euch im
vergangenen Video erzählt haben ist
seine neoimperium auf dem besten Wege
wieder eine Diktatur zu werden die in
der Welt den Ton angibt und auf eine
Sache könnt ihr euch auch verlassen wir
werden dieses Thema noch viel
gründlicher auseinander nehmen und vor
allem die unglaublich wichtige Rolle
China hast die wir aufgrund der
aktuellen Geschehnisse in der Ukraine
bisher etwas vernachlässigen mussten
also schreibt uns was ihr von Russlands
Wachstum Einfluss haltet abonniert
unseren Kanal und aktiviert auch das
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen wir freuen uns natürlich
auch über eine Spende dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den PayPal Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video mach's gut und bis bald